>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING SATURDAY."
IT'S A STORY THAT HAS
DISAPPEARED FROM MOST HEADLINES
IN RECENT YEARS AS AMERICANS
HAVE TURNED THEIR ATTENTION TO
OTHER ISSUES.
BUT IN PARTS OF THIS COUNTRY,
THE OPIOID CRISIS AND DEATHS
FROM DRUG OVERDOSES MAY BE WORSE
THAN EVER.
STARTING THIS WEEK, A LANDMARK
TRIAL BEGAN IN WEST VIRGINIA
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT IS SUING
THREE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
DISTRIBUTORS.
THE CASE HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFT THE WAY THIS
NATION BATTLING ADDICTION AS
WELL AS ALTER THE LIVES OF
MILLIONS OF FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED.
>> OVERDOSE --
>> IN 2017, A FIRE CHIEF IN
HUNTINGTON, WEST VIRGINIA,
BECAME AN ACCIDENTAL STAR WHEN
JAN RADER WAS FEATURED IN THE
DOCUMENTARY "HEROINE."
>> 23-YEAR-OLD FAMILY.
SHE'S DEAD, OVERDOSE.
>> Reporter: AT THE TIME IT
SEEMED THANKS TO AGGRESSIVE WORK
LIKE HERS THE COUNTRY WAS
FINALLY MAKING REAL PROGRESS.
IN ITS TWO-DECADE-LONG STRUGGLE
AGAINST THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC COME
HAS CLAIMED THE LIVES OF MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION AMERICANS.
>> THERE'S SUCH A RIPPLE EFFECT
WHEN SOMEBODY OVERDOSES AND DIES
THAT THERE'S SO MUCH COLLATERAL
DAMAGE THAT YOU CAN'T EVEN
MEASURE IT.
>> ON FRIDAY, RADER TOOK THE
STAND AS A LEAD WITNESS IN A
LANDMARK LAWSUIT AGAINST THREE
OPIOID WHOLESALERS.
McKESSON CORPS,
AMERISOURCEBERGEN, AND CARDINAL
HEALTH.
THE POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WEST VIRGINIA'S LOOKING
FOR WOULD GO TO OFFSET THE
SOARING COSTS OF FIRST
RESPONDERS, JAILS, AND DRUG
TREATMENT CENTERS.
>> WE WERE IMPROVING, AND THEN
THE PANDEMIC CAME ALONG, AND
THERE WERE A LOT OF RELAPSES.
>> Reporter: RELAXES AND DEATHS
WHICH INCREASED BY AS MUCH AS
TWO-THIRDS FROM THE PRIOR YEAR.
>> ON DRUGS, PD REQUESTING --
>> IT AFFECTS OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS TREMENDOUSLY.
THEY ARE NOT JUST GOING ON
OVERDOSES AND OVERDOSE DEATHS,
THEY'RE GOING ON OVERDOSES OF
THEIR FRIENDS.
PEOPLE THEY GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL WITH.
>> Reporter: WHAT HAPPENED THE
OTHER DAY?
>> ONE OF MY STAFF RESPONDED TO
AN OVERDOSE IN THE ALLEY.
THREE PEOPLE HAD OVERDOSED AT
THE SAME TIME.
>> Reporter: THREE?
>> THREE.
>> Reporter: AMANDA COLEMAN RUNS
HARMONY HOUSE WHICH HELPS PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
ANOTHER PROBLEM THAT HAS REACHED
EPIDEMIC PROPORTIONS IN THE LAST
YEAR.
WHAT COMES FIRST, THE
HOMELESSNESS OR THE DRUG USE?
>> ALMOST ALWAYS THE DRUG USE.
>> Reporter: OVER THE PAST
DECADE, THE THREE DEFENDANTS IN
THE WEST VIRGINIA LAWSUIT HAVE
SHIPPED MORE THAN 81 MILLION
DOSES OF PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS TO
THIS COUNTY WHICH ONLY HAS A
POPULATION OF 91,000.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC, USERS WHO
START ON PRESCRIPTION PILLS ARE
FAR MORE LIKELY TO TURN TO MORE
DEADLY OPTIONS LIKE HEROIN OR
FENTANYL.
THE PROBLEM HAS BECOME
GENERATIONAL.
ADDICTS WHO ARE NOW ADULTS
RAISING CHILDREN IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY'RE
SURROUNDED BY DRUG ABUSE.
HOW DO YOU BREAK THAT CYCLE?
>> WE'VE GOT TO DO LOTS OF WORK
TO PREVENT OUR KIDS FROM USING,
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
SUPPORTS THAT MAYBE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING IN A HOUSEHOLD.
BUT WE'VE ALSO GOT TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE USING RIGHT NOW
SO WE CAN REDUCE THE TRAUMA ON
THE KIDS THAT ARE LIVING IN
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS.
>> Reporter: AND YOU BELIEVE
DRUG MANUFACTURERS OR
DISTRIBUTORS SHOULD PAY FOR
THAT?
>> I DO.
I'VE NOT MET A PERSON WHO WOKE
UP ONE DAY AND STUCK A NEEDLE IN
THEIR ARM, YOU KNOW.
I'VE HEARD THE ARGUMENT THAT
IT'S NOT PILLS, IT'S NOT PILLS
IT STARTS WITH PILLS.
I'VE NEVER MET A PERSON WHO
DIDN'T START WITH PILLS.
AND OFTENTIMES THEY WERE PUSHED
ON THEM.
I JUST -- I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
BELIEVE THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT.
>> Reporter: THERE'S SOME --
THERE HAS TO BE SOME PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, WE ALL MAKE A
DECISION.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT A PERSON WHO
GREW UP IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THERE WASN'T ENOUGH FOOD, THEY
WERE LEFT ALONE FOR LONG PERIODS
OF TIME, MAYBE THEY WERE TRADED
FOR DRUGS, WHAT HOPE DO THEY
HAVE, WHAT OPTIONS DO THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE, WHAT DO THEY
KNOW THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN THAT?
>> Reporter: THE NUMBER OF
OVERDOSES HAS CONTINUED TO RISE.
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WOULD LIKELY BE FAR
WORSE IF NOT FOR THE RECENT
WIDESPREAD USE OF NALOXONE.
SOMETIMES KNOWN BY ITS BRAND
NAME, NARCAN.
AN EMERGENCY MEDICATION THAT
REVERSES THE EFFECTS OF OPIATES.
>> THE ONLY THING THAT YOU NEED
TO HAVE TO GET INTO LONG-TERM
TREATMENT IS YOU HAVE TO BE
ALIVE.
AND SO WHETHER WE KEEP YOU ALIVE
WITH NARCAN OR OTHER MEANS, YOU
KNOW, WE -- YOU HAVE TO KEEP YOU
ALONE, AND THEN WE TRY TO GET
YOU INTO TREATMENT.
>> Reporter: LAWSUITS IN OTHER
STATES MAY FOLLOW.
[ SIRENS ]
>> Reporter: BUT WEST VIRGINIA
IS WHERE THE CRISIS FIRST
UNFOLDED.
AND RADER BELIEVES WITH THE
RIGHT RESOURCES IT CAN BE A
NATIONAL EXAMPLE OF HOW IT ENDS.
>> WE HAVE TO HEAL THESE PEOPLE.
WE CAN'T -- WE'VE DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB HERE DEVELOPING
PROGRAMS, WE KNOW WHAT WORKS, WE
KNOW SOME THINGS THAT DON'T
WORK.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE THAT
WE NEED A LOT OF MONEY TO DO
THAT.
>> Reporter: WE REACHED OUT TO
ALL THREE DEFENDANTS NAMED IN
THE WEST VIRGINIA LAWSUIT.
THEY SAY AS WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTORS THEY DO NOT
MANUFACTURE, MARKET, OR
PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS AND PLAY A
LIMITED ROLE IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
AND DENY DRIVING THE DEMAND FOR
OPIOIDS.
THEY ADD THEY HAVE FOLLOWED THE
LAW AND ARE COMMITTED TO
PREVENTING DRUG ABUSE.
THERE ARE TWO OTHER TRIALS
ALREADY UNDER WAY, ABOUT TO
START, IN NEW YORK AND
CALIFORNIA, IN ADDITION TO WEST
VIRGINIA.
>> I CAN'T GET THAT 81 MILLION
FIGURE OUT OF MY HEAD.
WHY IS WEST VIRGINIA GROUND
ZERO?
>> IT'S WHERE IT STARTED AND IT
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN.
ONE OF THE HEARTBREAKING THINGS
TO THINK ABOUT IS LITTLE KIDS
GROWING UP IN THAT ENVIRONMENT,
SURROUNDED BY DRUG ABUSE SINCE
THEY WERE -- THAT'S THE ONLY
WORLD THEY KNOW.
>> THE CYCLE AS YOU TALKED
ABOUT.
I NOT AS WE'RE NOT OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC, BUT AS WE'RE COMING
OUT OF IT TO SOME DEGREE, IT IS
PROBLEMS LIKE THIS THAT PEOPLE
DIDN'T HAVE TIME FOR SO TO SPEAK
TO WATCH AND OVERLOOK.
AND W